[Music]
I am Maximo for FX guide.com for Wired
we're a digital was formed 20 years ago
and has worked on over 40 incredible
films this week one of those films
received an Oscar nomination and is in
the running to win Dorner Planet of the
Apes but a real surprise was the
omission of The Hobbit the Battle of the
five armies which was also done by
wetter this last of the Tolkien films
was an omission that was a real upset
the film has vastly complicated
simulations terrific character work and
some of the most breathtaking
environments much of the earliest
attention of The Lord of the Rings films
was actually gained from the use of the
crowd simulation software massive in the
vast battle sequences and it's only
therefore fitting that in The Hobbit it
should end with some remarkable battles
on a scale that not even weather had
previously attempted in this film were
to deploy their new army manager
production tool that allowed director
Peter Jackson to visualize the battles
and decide how to film them the
filmmakers still use the incredible
massive software developed in New
Zealand for the final shots but massive
is more of an animation and postal army
manager by comparison is faster and was
used earlier in production bridging the
gap in real time between previews and
the final massive shots the Battle of
the five armies also show the incredible
power of the new Manuka renderer which
was first seen actually in a handful of
shots in dawn at Planet of the Apes the
350,000 lines of new code delivered
renders of vastly complex fluid and
destruction simulations and also very
detailed character work in only way that
Peter Jackson can put on the screen
while the first Lord of the Rings film
is remembered for its battles it's the
digital character work with creatures
such as Gollum that has made weatr a
regular contender at almost every Oscars
race since they started in this film the
Laketown attack by small gifts every bit
as strong and is built inside one of the
most elaborate computer simulations
imaginable smokes wings actually drive
air simulations in this closed volume
that's been built for the all-digital
sequence
the air flow fluid seems then feed fire
simulations which in turn drive the
incredibly detailed building destruction
the buildings of course collapse and
their rigidbody simulations then
interact with the fluid simulations of
the lake this in turn triggers smoke and
steam to rise up which can actually be
seen vortexing by the very wings of the
dragon as it flies by all of this of
course while smoke is breathing fire its
volumetric speeding Richard body's
fading fluid sins while visually needing
to stay very much in keeping with the
earlier films it is remarkable how far
wetter has come with its pipeline
producing today's some of the most
complex imagery in terms of both
animation and rendering of middle-earth
or perhaps just testament to how
competitive the category is that a film
as good as the five armies didn't even
get a nomination don't forget subscribe
for more behind the scenes action I'm
Mike Seymour for wide
you
[Music]